and I think we need to get to a point
where I I mean guys we have to be a bit
skeptical that rich famous men are are
rape and women like that I mean this
really doesn't make any sense and my
question is what is assault what we need
we need to get clear definitions so we
can determine if this stuff happened but
now now we say consent what is consent
what's not consent and it just gets
really confusing to the general public
so you know we can wait till the facts
come out of the case I just I have a
hard time believing that
rich and famous really needs need rape
women
sorry for being the one to say it but
that's just my opinion on it